so brittany um i'm so curious with this
and you kind of touched on it
i want to dive in a little more i was
like who's going into journalism right
like what because it is
andrew talks about a lot it's a it's in
some ways a dying industry in some ways
a growing industry depending on where
you're looking at
um in terms of how we're getting news we
can talk about a lot but it's
it's definitely changing and the pay
is also getting more bifurcated
depending on your entry level and that
sort of thing and you said
first like i'm coming in with the same
title as people been there for 30 years
um now luckily for you as a startup so
it was less intimidating but i'm sure
some competitors had really young people
in some of these roles as well
um so who gets into this and
maybe even why yeah there are a lot of
different sims variations of journalists
that's kind of how i see like if you're
in video game starting character lots of
different kinds of people who could be a
journalist
a company similar to ours at the time
was axios and they had lots of younger
people who actually went to college with
who are still killing the game who i
love very deeply
and i think folks who were going into
the startup space
were people who kind of wanted to
reinvent the wheel i think kind of the
og jonah peretti
buzzfeed buzzfeed minded people who saw
that there's something that wasn't
clicking
in the industry either and how they were
consuming news or they they were
disenfranchised by and just enchanted by
it and they wanted to
change so kind of like creative minded
folks where
they cared about writing and about news
copy but they wanted to make uh you know
move fast and break things that's not
what they say in silicon valley right
it was like that was the centralizing
motivation i think that i might fall
under that bucket a little bit
then there's the folks who when they
were 9 and 10 years old have been
reading the wall street journal because
that's all they know when they're from
connecticut no offense to connecticut
right
i'm from connecticut and you should give
it all of the [ __ ] it deserves as a long
islander i'll say it
um where it's generational either their
family works in business or their family
is in the industry because there are
many people who their grandfather their
grandmother worked in publishing and
then
and then it trickles down right so there
were those people who are like hardened
by the ap
style book and they work at wires and
they work at papers and they're
wonderful journalists but their demeanor
and their approach
is very different they believe in mass
objectivity
again this is a big push pulled in the
industry itself even with within
my age group and i think it translates
as you go up and up and up to the vets
um and then you have people who are just
rich and that can cross through
everything you know and i came from a
comfortable upbringing i'm very
self-aware of that it's very difficult
to be working class
and be an entry-level journalist at
least in washington dc or in
a kind of national journalist role
because if you squeeze in and look at
the papers like your little neighborhood
paper
they probably pay their writers minimum
wage
if you are a college student with loans
you can barely afford your own health
care maybe your family can barely afford
them on health care
you don't have time to piddle making
like little you know
articles for 15 bucks i mean it's a huge
issue
so then that may have a pipeline problem
where it's only folks from ivy league
colleges
and gw right who are wealthy
so you end up getting predominantly i
think
classist or reporters who have no
ability to sympathize or empathize with
any other class structure
and predominantly white um they're not
mutually exclusive
and i think that it's a problem in news
rooms but to answer your question i
think that's the general archetype of
people
who want to go in and i think sprinkled
among them are like bleeding heart
people
right who like want to save the world
and they want to bring truth to power
ideally a newsroom has all of them but i
think those are the kind of folks who
who at least start right so this is
this is the crux of it i'm so i'm so so
fascinated by this and i
feel like you've seen enough of all of
the world to give a fun perspective on
it because i'm excited to talk to you um
let's talk about journalism today and i
want to be curious about pros and cons
and i think it's really easy
i am guilty of this and don't feel bad
about it like
i'm [ __ ] on the media all the time
um and there's tons of criticism and i'd
like to bucket those out too but
i think the media does some things
really well today
um i do think there are some either
positive trends or
so i wanted to give credence to like the
good stuff too so let's talk a journal
today
if i had to do a pro con list um what
would you say
what is what are the good parts what are
the pros of where journalism's going
today i have thoughts too but i feel
like you should start
i think from it selfishly from a
newsroom perspective i think we're
the most diverse we've ever been we have
a long way to go
but because of that we're able to cover
stories with nuance whether whether it's
race
or gender or any kind of intersectional
cut class very well
look what's happening right now with the
shogun trial during the
floyd protests over the summer how that
intersected into the election
i i at least saw more folks on
television more folks and print by lines
who were unafraid to be themselves
i i always give journalist journalists
to shout out he's my friend wes
lowry formerly of the washington post
now of cbs 60 minutes
he's only a few years older than me has
a pulitzer
black and he kind of very famously left
the post
being very very outspoken on twitter
about
the racial inequities within that
newsroom and within news
and that empowered a lot of us to do
similar things online
and being able to and this is maybe like
a 1a
use all of that on social media to take
away
some of the opacity between
our sources our readers our process
and us as personalities that is i think
tantamount to growing media trust and i
think something that we do
very well now of course there's tons of
space to grow
but i don't think you talked to
journalists 10 years ago about now
who would ever think that we'd have the
leash to be able to say the things we do
that's a good one i i the one one of the
things i said doing realized i i said
transparency in a weird way i think
there's things that are not transparent
but
i think reports of what's going on in
the new york times newsroom with
washington post newsroom or how people
are writing stories
or like twitter in a weird way can be
really raw and really personal because
it's
it's the personality the tweeter and the
tweet right there [ __ ] like theoret
besides our politicians that get people
to review their tweets
it's usually the human um and i think
that's cool you get to know the
reporters
um so that is
to me at least in the long run a good
thing
right because it's transparent there's
no like back room
um editorial process as much as there
used to be i'm sure there are and
that's the thing um the other one i had
was that it's
the 24 7 aspect i think it drives people
nuts but that is theoretically a good
thing where you're always there but
the biggest one is like it's never been
easier to report like anyone who's made
bad for some
bigger behemoths but anyone can
hop on a camera and live stream and be a
reporter i don't know your thoughts on
that but that feels like
generically generally positive i have
a lot of mixed thoughts about it i call
it the ratatouille problem that anyone
can be a chef
thing because all right i believe in the
democratization
of of the media process of becoming a
journalist i think the barrier to entry
should be way low
but with that power becomes lots of
responsibility
and if you do not have the training or
at least people around you
you can either misuse it on purpose or
by accident which we've seen a lot of in
the last four to
eight years people and this is not
citizen journalism
right this is not folks during an
insurrection or uprising
going to twitter and recording and
getting information out there
that helps us tell the story that is
valuable i mean that changes the
politics
and democracies of certain countries i
want to like flag that as separate but i
think
people joe and jill on the street
who then start their own news blog which
again can have lots of important news
value
but they can use that
without the proper training or resources
or fact checking knowledge
and spread disinformation i hate this
term fake news which
incorrect information in which it
proliferates because it's so easy to go
viral with the right headline with the
right packaging
they could stumble on it by accident uh
and then now there's a mess on our hands
of how do we untangle this
um there was this column in the
washington post last week and there was
this little
fact i want to cite that since the 1970s
trust in the news has fallen 70 70 to
40.
that's huge social media making it more
democratized has impacted it by a little
bit
when we talk about the cons that's where
my biggest con is
i think i love that you said that
because some of these pros and cons it's
like they're all
most of them are double-edged swords
right like 24-hour news
exciting you can always get anything
same times like do we ever take a break
no driving anybody nuts um
youtube's algorithm facebook's algorithm
as of now doesn't really care
if you're the washington post versus
z's q and on weekly podcast if people
are clicking on it
if people are interested and excited
about it or just like
find the you know if it's just click
bait it's still going to get
um a lot of views and interests and
excitement and that is the big challenge
[Music]
[Music]
you